[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes coming to you on the 26th of
January Thursday
I'm Katie balls the spectator's
political editor coming up on the show
money problems are piling up for Rishi
sunic and the Tories can he get a grip
on Tory's sleeves once and for all I'll
be speaking to Isabel Hardman and John
Curtis
as Russia ramps up its defense Ukraine
has made a plea to the West for more
arms and tanks but what role do tanks
play in modern warfare we've got Mike
Martin and Richard Barons to discuss
how much trouble is Joe Biden in a paper
trail of classified documents has been
found in his home breaching National
Security protocol classified documents
are a constant theme in American
politics but other figures like Trump
Clinton and now Mike Pence facing the
same Scandal can Biden brush is off
Freddie gray our deputy and it joins me
now
the English language is facing a war on
Words groups are seeking to remove
certain words in this day and Asia
deemed offensive some on the list may
surprise you Lionel Shriver has a story
finally what are some of the dangers
when it comes to restoring Fine Art
there have been some highs and loads of
art restoration over centuries but can
the paintings ever truly go back to
their original condition and should they
I speak to Igor taroni Lalique
before we get going thank you to
canonical genuity wealth management for
sponsoring this episode of the week in
60 minutes can a quarter experience
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer unwavering support and
challenging times because it can do
wealth.com for more information and
don't forget to also subscribe to The
Spectators YouTube channel just click
the Subscribe button at the bottom of
the video and tap the Bell icon so you
never miss an episode
first up Tori sleaze is back at the top
of the agenda for the Signet government
but not because he wants it there is a
worrying sign for the Prime Minister who
at the beginning of his Premiership
promised the country he would move on
from the sleeves of the Johnson era
cancunek escaped from the pie laboratory
scandals joining me now is Isabel
Hardman assistant editor and political
scientist John Curtis
John Isabelle thank you for joining
spectator TV this week Isabel it's been
a real week for the return of Tory
sleaze and how much of this is to do for
Rishi sulac and how much is to do with
Legacy issues as we might call them I
think it's interesting that there is
really a sort of Rishi sunach-shaped
hole in a lot of this in the it's
obviously Legacy issues regarding Boris
Johnson and his fascinating personal
finances and then Nadim zahari who was
also uh settling a historical tax bill
or historic in terms of its size I think
uh and Rishi soon it really is appearing
again out of control sort of not at the
center of all these events he's said to
be angry and not speaking to Nadine
zahawi because the highway apparently
didn't give him the full details of his
tax uh his tax affairs from the outset
so he's been surprised by some of the
newspaper coverage of the route which is
definitely not where you want to be if
you are prime minister and again at
Prime Minister's questions this week he
didn't really seem like he had a grip on
the situation he was very much leaning
on the importance of due process which
is important but the fact that he was
saying since then more information has
come to light it just seems as though he
doesn't have the sufficient command over
his party
John at the end of the day we can go
through these various scandals and as
Isabel points to some of these uh to do
with Boris Johnson Richard Cena because
obviously inherited quite a few but to
voters are they going to be saying well
this is this story not that Tory or does
it just look like a big problem for the
conservative party
well of course we are talking about a
conservative party who's declining the
polls at least initially was instigated
I mean not So Much by allegations of
sleaze as of somebody I.E the Prime
Minister not following the rules that he
everybody else was required to meet in
rules that were rather painful for
people to meet now to be honest the tax
Affairs of a temporary Chancellor in a
caretaker government which is all Nadeem
sahawi ever was and a politician who is
not that well known isn't going to have
the same kind of impact on the public
that the allegations surrounding Boris
Johnson did and to some degree still
have
um that said yep um just over half of
people by uh as pulled by yougov Nadeem
sahal his company where he made a lot of
the money that's at stake
um uh said that he should resign in only
around 20 took the opposite view so but
certainly think the seems seem to think
Mr sahabi should go I mean so far as you
know it doesn't have any immediate
short-term impact while we've only had
one opinion poll so far conducted really
since this uh story broke it's people
poding for GB news they already had the
conservatives down at 21 they just
simply have the conservatives still done
at 21 and I think might just need to
bear in mind here the conservatives are
already so far behind the in the polls
that whether or not this particular
story is going to add to uh the
conservatives difficulties as a party is
perhaps uncertain I think what is
perhaps more interesting and following
on from Isabelle's comments is that
perhaps this will be adding to voters
information about how competent and
effective they think
is they've been getting to have some of
their doubts about that and I think you
know more broadly I think Mr it's long
been obvious is somebody who is very
articulate
um when he's got things under control
but doesn't always come across so well
when he's under pressure when he's
things are coming at him that he's not
necessarily anticipating and of course
for a prime minister that latter quality
is crucial and perhaps Mr sunac is
gradually learning much like Gordon
Brown did it's not similar to similar
character that when you're in the top
job you've got to be able to deal with
the things that are the unexpected and
that's one of the things that voters of
course expect you to be able to do and
ultimately it's about
um the Tories could stay where they are
in the polls
um I think some touring MPS always blame
Richard Cena for that but lots did come
before he needs to lift his party up
closer to where his approval ratings are
or at least where they were when he
first entered number 10. and he said uh
on the steps of Downing Street his
government would be one of Integrity
which I think lots of people thought was
an end to some of the scandals so is is
it a problem for him if he cannot I
suppose move to I suppose making
politics boring which is something that
they have been boasting about trying to
do for some time which this week isn't
going so well no I I think it I mean I
think it is a problem that politics
isn't boring that he hasn't made his
party suddenly seem slick and as though
it's not going to you know trip over its
own shoelaces I think a bigger problem
will be if in the budgets in March
there's not some kind of indication at
the very least of tax cuts and of the
the tax burden going down notorious
aren't expecting a dramatic reduction
but they want a plan for tax cuts and a
plan that will see them going into the
election with a much lower tax burden
they at the moment aren't sure whether
Rishi sunak and Jeremy Hunter really
sincere in leading a conservative
government they accept that they're
since they're in leading a boring
government even if that doesn't seem to
be happening uh to them at the moment
but they really will kick off if there's
not a direction of travel on the tax
burden this this debate by Tory MP is
about the budget in March really goes to
the heart of the Dilemma of the
conservative party at the moment it's
not it it's arguably part of the legacy
of which is sunaka's chancellor but the
problem that The Angst that the
conservative party has been dealing with
it was The Angst that lay behind the
leadership uh uh uh contest last summer
it's why Liz trust one is that the
conservative party is struggling with
the fact that it's presiding over record
levels of Taxation and record levels of
spending uh now arguably that's nothing
to do with it it's a consequence of
covid post covert the supply chain
difficulties High inflation and uh now
um uh the the difficulties uh within the
Public Services but the problem is that
um at the moment the pairing evidence
suggests that the focus of the public is
very much on the state of our Public
Services because the the real dilemma
facing a government and the labor party
would face the same dilemma if it goes
into office is we have the UK has a
fiscal crisis you know a fiscal crisis
the kind that we last experienced in the
1970s
but the Public Services despite these
high levels of spending are not
delivering and it's therefore very very
difficult for any government of any
color to pursue much in the way of tax
cuts uh against that backdrop the first
thing the conservatives have to be able
to do and again it's not a question of
passing legislation to ensure that the
ambulance turns up on time when there's
a strike the problem the government has
to solve is to make sure the ambulance
turns up on time when people aren't on
strike because at the moment minimum
service guarantees that the government
has in mind are not being met in
ordinary time and until the problems of
the Health Service and the problems to
some degree in education are resolved
it's going to be very very difficult for
any government to persuade voters that
tax cuts are the priority as opposed to
dealing with public service but of
course for many conservative politicians
that is an uncomfortable place to be but
unfortunately it's the place in which
the party finds itself and Israel on
that point I mean Rishi syrac seems to
grasp on the problems that John just
mentioned in the sense you look at those
five priorities and yes they're a free
which relate to the economy and what is
growth
um but that's not the same speed of a
growth plan as the trust sites for
example would want and instead there is
a big focus on the NHS on public
services and was talking about the
issues uh I mean the complaint is it's
more probably what a focus group would
say on those five priorities and but it
does reflect this now we have the growth
Group which is um you know many uh led
by uh former members of Liz truss's
cabinet they're already agitating as you
point to your tax cuts but do you think
there has been a period of reflection
which is that perhaps the next budget is
not only where tax cuts are if there are
going to be taxed because it's more
likely to be one probably two away in
terms of before the next election
I don't think within the party there's
been that period of reflection certainly
those who are very familiar with the the
broad spectrum of use across the party
they are expecting an indication of a
direction of travel in the next budget
but it's very interesting that the trust
group even those who dismiss that group
as in the words of one MP who I was
talking to yesterday deranged still say
but they do have a point about growth uh
and I think that's something that that
sunac should take seriously and not just
think these are you know not sore losers
but people who who don't know when to be
quiet and have a period of reflection or
idiots as he uh said of people here to
use the words of the Prime Minister and
that kind of thing goes down really
badly with conservative MPS you don't
have to be a political obsessive to know
that the Tory parties are very sensitive
Beast I mean it basically has the same
levels of emotional sensitivity as a 14
year old at school disco and I think
when you call MPS idiots in any party
and you're their leader that's not a
great idea it when you do it in the toy
party it's just a Surefire way of
winding them up yeah and of course when
he was saying idiots it was it was more
oh the public realized we don't need a
tax cuts now so it wasn't direct but I
think you didn't say my MPS are idiot
yeah that's what they heard it didn't
take much to join the Dotson and for
them to feel that
um John just finally
um you mentioned how the public are
still making up their minds in Russian
tunak um they may have made their minds
up on the past reusatory government
um but polls are not looking
particularly good for rishis you know is
there anything in terms of a positive
you're seeing
um from as we you know hit his first
three months as prime minister
well I mean one of the questions we were
asking about which is Sunnah because he
became prime minister is would he be
able to bring his party up to the kinds
of levels of popularity that he
personally enjoyed or would we find that
eventually his personal popularity fell
towards the kinds of levels that were
closer to that of his party now he is
still much more popular than his party
but the Gap is narrowed and it's as far
as he is concerned the Gap is narrowed
in the wrong way I.E his own personal
popularity has declined most opinion
polls now ask people whether they
approve or disapprove of how he's doing
his job do you think he's doing well or
badly are they satisfied or dissatisfied
now have vicious sunach in negative
territory whereas when he first became
prime minister he was in a positive
territory so he's he's been
undergraduate Decline and you know
therefore his ability you know both to
to handle the immediate political fire
but also in the end to deal with the
problems of Public Services the problem
with the Health Service to try to deal
with some of the industrial unrestless
kicking around where frankly uh
certainly the industrial rests inside
the Health Service it is the it is the
government that people blame not the
trade unions until you can start to deal
with some of this and demonstrate the
leadership on those kinds of things uh
then frankly the risk is that he's going
to end up being further in that
direction but on growth by the way look
this is not a source of political
division
every politician I mean the labor party
has been constantly going on about the
need for growth every politician
realizes that given we have a debt to
GDP ratio of around 100 uh that we have
uh a taxes at record levels spending at
record levels of GDP that the only way
we're going to get out of this is by
achieving economic growth the argument
is about how you best achieve economic
growth and it's probably going to be an
essential debate between our political
parties between now and the general
election
thank you John thank you Isabel
to ramp up its armed forces the case for
sending inventory over to Ukraine has
revealed the limitations to European
tanks Matt galliotti looks at the West
hollowed armies in the magazine this
week to discuss I'm joined Now by Mike
Martin and Richard barons
rich and Mike thank you for joining
spectator TV this week to kick things
off Richard can you explain what this is
a debate about tanks has all been about
so at the heart of this is the Ukrainian
government's plea to have 300 main
battle tanks and 500 large artillery
guns to do two important things one is
to break up and stop the Russian
defensive that they know will appear at
some point early on in 2023 and the
other is to have the land combat power
to be able to shove the Russians out of
Ukraine and what that has provoked is a
debate in the west about should Ukraine
be given these tanks and if so uh what
type and how many
and Mike I wanted to could you just
describe what role these tanks play in
the wall because um I think at earlier
stages and conflicts have been demands
for different you know for certain
weapons uh why is it the tanks in our
students that in the the country really
does need I think Ukraine is about to go
on the offensive I mean that's what's
going to happen uh once the spring thaw
has happened and what tanks are really
really useful for is punching through
defensive positions or front lines and
and they're highly maneuverable and they
take their Firepower with them so you
can either go through Russian units or
around them and so you're right we have
gone from you know originally anti-tank
missiles to air defense to artillery to
now we're asking for tanks and actually
what's happened is that's tracked the
stages of the war primarily at the
beginning Ukraine was on the defensive
but now they've retaken three key areas
back off the Russians and they're ready
to go onto the offensive so they need
the Weaponry to allow them to do that
and Richard why is it that Germany has
really dragged its feet here because we
now um you know later this week finally
had Germany said they will send tanks
and also giving permission and for
others to send tanks that they have made
What specifically is causing that delay
and how long it's taken to get there
well there seem to be three main reasons
the the first is a general German
cultural resistance to getting involved
in the business of War given their clear
historical Legacy and roughly half the
German population just doesn't like to
do war and we would understand why that
is secondly because Germany despite all
advice from its allies built quite a
dependency on Russian energy and Russian
trade and there were legitimate concerns
last year about how much damage
supporting Ukraine would do to the
German economy and prosperity
and thirdly and I think uh more
tellingly of late a concern that if
Germany lent more weight to the
Ukrainian military effort this would
give Russia the excuse that it was
looking for to expand the war from a war
between Russia and Ukraine to a war
between Russia and NATO and indeed
Russia defines the war now as a war with
NATO whatever we like to think and Mike
do you think there is a real risk that
actually the decision this week is about
the Germany has no green lit this
um obviously other countries the UK came
out before that to say they would send
tanks
um is that going to lead to you know a
toughening up in terms of the rhetoric
and potentially an escalation of this
war
um I think
um it's actually hard to argue that
Russia can escalate this War I mean it's
it's a it's already a genocidal War
we're finding Mass graves in forests
um they could expand it to some other
countries but all of the neighboring
countries are covered by the NATO
Article Five so Putin would have to be
completely mad to do that I mean the
ukrainians have held back the Russian
army what do we think the combined
armies of NATO are going to do then the
only other option really is the nuclear
escalation I know there's been a lot of
chat about that a lot of it from Russia
talking about these unimaginable
consequences but actually that's
actually stopped that that was a lot
there was a lot of that at the beginning
of the conflict and it became quite
clear that the Russians were bluffing
because they realized that the use of
nuclear weapons in Europe particularly
when on the other side of the conflict
are three other nuclear Powers Britain
France and the US
basically would make Putin's position
completely untenable there's no way that
that would be allowed to stand and so
the Russians have quietly dropped the
nuclear posturing as well so there might
be a an upping of the rhetoric I mean
frankly who cares
um they can up the rhetoric as much as
they like if the ukrainians have got a
tank Brigade which is you know if you've
got 120 to 150 tanks that's a tank
Brigade that's significantly upgrades
their capability and will enable them to
launch an offensive you know perhaps in
the south of the country that cuts the
Russian troops in Crimea off from the
Russian troops in the donbass like this
is really significant stuff
um now Ukraine have called for 300 tanks
and so Richard where are we at in terms
of the numbers that we expect them to
roughly get to and also what is the
number that was uh potentially lead to
uh Ukraine making so such inroads that
perhaps uh people start to talk about
this you know wall reaching an end or is
that not actually something that's on
the horizon no matter the number of
Tanks
so Ukraine has asked for 300 tanks uh
you know that's the top end of their ask
so they would know they're unlikely to
get 300 and they would know that
whatever number they got on any given
day a number would be broken or out of
action and as things stand depending on
the the details that emerge in the
coming days they might get about 120
more up-to-date uh Western tanks
um this will be Complicated by the fact
that there'll be several different types
each type needs its own Logistics supply
chain and its own Fleet of maintainers
and it's going to take some time frankly
to to master that but as Ukraine looks
at uh the the numbers and the way the
war is likely to go this year the first
thing it needs is is tanks and other
things including an awful lot of
ammunition to break up the prospect of a
Russian offensive probably coming out of
the donbass at some point and when
Ukraine has to go on the offensive you
can't win the war just by defending when
Ukraine goes on the offensive to take
its country entry back it'll have to do
it in sensible bite-sized chunks and
when it does that it will want to have
three to seven times as many tanks in
principle to defeat the defending
Russian armor and other systems so it to
concentrate enough force it needs to
acquire a number and I think 120 of
several different types is a likely to
mean that they they fall short a bit and
falling short means this war remains
pretty much deadlocked and more likely
than not to run into 2024.
and like what do you think on on that
point then is a reasonable best case
scenario for Ukraine in the coming
months when it comes to that spring
offensive
um so I think it's important to note
that both sides are going to try and
launch a spring offensive I think a lot
of commentators argue that the Russians
will have an offensive in the ukrainians
will have a counter-offensive I think
Ukraine has long had designs on a spring
offensive as well
um that really those two offensives in
different areas are going to dominate
the spring and the summer probably
stretching into the Autumn for Ukraine
uh the most obvious place doesn't mean
that that's where they're going to do it
is to go south from zapparesia cutting
the Russian forces into if they can get
to the coast the Sea of azov
um the next most likely place is up in
the Northeast because if they if they
cut us across there then they actually
cut the Russian supply lines running
down into donbass
um the Russians on the other hand are
very very keen to finish filling out
lehansk and Donetsk which are the two
provinces in the east of the country
that make up the donbass and this is
what Putin's has claimed as his War aims
so it's quite interesting both sides are
actually trying to make gains in
different areas you know from the
recurring point of view they're trying
to defeat the Russian military and from
the Russian point of view they're trying
to just fill in those two provinces in
the east
and then Richard I suppose there's a
question which is uh particularly when
we've seen in the UK media this week of
well if these countries send tanks what
is left in terms of their own Supply and
there's been lots of reports about how
actually the UK military
um is pretty depleted as is
um so we're talking about you know NATO
armies but
um how much fits really are um lots of
these European countries in terms of
their armies
so I think this is one of the most
profoundly important political questions
of of of our time and and it's the one
that governments are least inclined to
want to Grapple with that the fact is
that the UK armed forces and and the
Armed Forces of uh most of our European
neighbors are are not Quote Match fit to
play their part in the revitalization of
NATO which NATO has constructed in a new
strategic concept and a new set of plans
and a new force model it's rolling out
um this year and we should remember that
we last reviewed our defenses in 2021 we
produce the integrated review that as a
matter of policy made the Army smaller
and decided to not recapitalize it from
the the fleet of stuff it has now which
was issued in the 1990s until uh later
this decade it was actually as into the
next decade and then the war in Ukraine
occurred and we are now locked in this
confrontation with Russia which I think
shows absolutely no signs of going away
for at least half a generation
so so the fact is despite
um potholes the the challenge with
education The Perils of NHS reform and
all of that we now have to revitalize
our defense for the world we really live
in and and that means matching what
Germany has said it will do France last
week has said it will do which is to to
lift defense spending now not in a few
years time in order to play our part in
uh greater European uh security if we
don't do this
um we'll be vulnerable we'll lose our
place of influence in NATO and the bill
will be greater when we eventually get
there so I imagine there's a very stiff
debate going on in Whitehall but my view
will be our political leaders are
failing us if they do not grasp the
defense nettle now in this urgent moment
of need and yeah we have a situation
where she's Cenac has not repeated some
of the pledges of his predecessor Liz
truss when it comes to defense spending
and partly because as you say so many
pressures on public finances right now
and the cost of living crisis so I
suppose I'm like just thinking ahead to
the future of warfare as we just heard
from Richard there was there was a pivot
in recent years talking more about
Modern Warfare
um about
um you know smaller armies uh how lots
of Wars be fought in lots of different
ways but do you think the Ukraine war
has been a reminder that actually we do
need to have big surprise when it comes
to the traditional means of combat
what's happened over the last year in
the conversation over UK defense happens
regularly to all countries uh when
they're talking about defense new
technologies come along and everyone
decides that actually they they can do
the same but they're cheaper so we can
get rid of some of the old capabilities
usually armor infantry it costs a lot to
you know pay all these people to sit and
do nothing and then when we come to war
we realize that actually to win Wars you
need infantry and if you have infantry
then you need tanks artillery and all
the other Suite of land capabilities so
it's not enough to have the latest
technology of course you do need that we
do need to be able to operate in the
Cyber domain we do need satellites Etc
but unfortunately they are they are an
addition they are not a replacement to
the the the the you know at the Triad of
delivering effects on land is is
infantry tanks and artillery and I'm
afraid that you cannot do away with
these if you want to be a serious
warfighting country
so more tanks all round thank you Mike
thank you Richard
Biden's docu Saga shows no sign of
stopping now Mike Pence has also been
caught with classifieds at his home
which American politician hasn't become
a national security threat Freddie gray
our deputy and adjoins me now
Freddie thank you for joining spectator
TV this week great pleasure Katie
um you've written the politics column
um and we're talking about the Biden
files tell us more well uh this story
has has been rumbling away uh the
documents were first found in Joe
Biden's home in November November the
2nd six days before the midterms
elections but the story only came out
funnily enough in January that these
sensitive documents uh that uh
classified documents uh had been
uncovered in Biden's one of Biden's
offices
and then there's been more uh files
they're sort of sprouting up like
mushrooms all over Joe Biden's
properties some in his Wilmington home
in his garage where he Parks his
precious Corvette uh some in his
personal library and Biden says there's
no there there he says this is a sort of
minor stories of accidental filing error
that everybody's making too big of us
about the problem for him is it's very
embarrassing because there was this
story about Donald Trump in the summer
and his files at Mar-A-Lago which the
FBI raided his home and Biden went on TV
and said uh how could anyone be that
irresponsible and so he's got egg on his
face it's pretty embarrassing and the
drama of the story might be yet to come
because what it might Point towards is
the office in which those first files
were first found
uh is at the Penn Biden Center and
there's some lots of questions about how
the pen Biden Center was funded Joe
Biden was paid an enormous amount of
money
um by the University of Pennsylvania the
pen in pen Biden
um and The Whispers in Washington is
that there's a bigger Scandal there
so could this get
Joe Biden um you mentioned Donald Trump
and obviously investigation there and at
the time lots of people saying this
could rule out a return for him
um in terms of Joe Biden and his current
position but also whether he you know
goes for that next term could this have
an impact I think it could uh I think
he's very keen to say it's a nothing
burger at the moment but very
interestingly his chief of staff Ron
Clane who was really thought to be the
real president he was the guy who drove
everything within the administration he
quit this week and what I've heard is
that he quit because he knew he knows
that there's going to be more on this
story and it's not going to be pretty
and he's sort of getting out while the
going is good because it had been going
quite well for Joe Biden I mean the
midterms were not a disaster as they've
been expected to be it looked like the
economy was turning around and they came
into the New Year everybody expecting
Joe Biden would announce for 2024.
um but suddenly there's a bit of Doubt
creeping in if you remember I put it in
a covered piece a couple of weeks ago uh
that Joe Biden had gone off to San Juan
in the Caribbean for a holiday and he
was thought there to be talking to his
family about uh the big decision whether
he will run in 2024 because there's
obviously quite a lot of concern about
his health a lot of talk about whether
his mental faculties are quite up to it
and the speculation was that because he
was feeling buoyed by the midterms he
was feeling confident about where
America was going how his presidency was
going he was actually going to announce
quite soon that he would and so he would
put the question to bed as to whether uh
he he's going to stand in 2024. suddenly
now with this story all sorts of Doubt
is creeping in and there's a lot of
conspiracy theorizing particularly on
the right of American politics that
actually the Democrats have always
wanted to get rid of all senior
Democrats have always wanted to get rid
of Joe Biden and that and maybe Ron
Clane is the theory would be wrong
claimers of aware that this is all
coming
um
Joe bison racings have gone up uh since
the summer but they are now going down
again
um as the sort of Gloom uh around the
economy in this post-covered age sinks
in
the what people are saying about Ron
claim is that he realized that they've
actually had a pretty good run
um certainly since the the last few
months of uh the first two years abiding
the presidency and that now may be a
very good time to get out so
the the talk that Biden is going to
resign is suddenly back in Washington
whereas at the turn of the year
um it had sort of it started to go away
and and the fight to watch out for in
the coming days
will be uh the debt ceiling because Joe
Biden fancies himself as a as a tough
negotiator he thinks he's very good at
bipartisanship reaching across the aisle
working with the Republicans but the new
slim majority in the House of
Representatives are determined to make
this debt ceiling which is a sort of
perennial uh story in Washington and it
sounds very boring and it is quite
boring because it's just about getting
the government to agree to take on more
debt in order to fulfill its obligations
that could become uh it could go much
closer to the wire than it ever has
before and that could throw the whole
economy into turmoil and then cause more
trouble for Biden the fear uh there was
a very good piece by Ramesh panunaru in
the Washington post about the scariest
part about this debt ceiling crisis is
that Washington isn't scared both sides
are confident Republicans and Joe Biden
are confident and the Democrats are
confident they can engage in bring
internship and sort of push it right to
the edge the worry for Americans in the
American economy is that they push it
right over the edge
and is
the terms of Joe Biden's son Hunter
Biden because often we've seen stories
of the past about how um Hunter Biden's
emails you know and the the hardware
that was found so um you know you've had
some attack lines saying well this
person could actually be someone who is
vulnerable to being a security I have
some people would Target could that make
things worse for Joe Biden it could I
mean first of all it's quite funny uh
that Father and Son both have this habit
of leaving possibly very dangerous stuff
just lying around
um secondly the hunter Biden story has
been what right-wing media in America
have been banging on about for ages and
most establishment pro-democratic media
has said you know this is just a sort of
almost fake news it's not a real story
they have had to slowly accept that
there is a big story there which is that
Hunter Biden Joe Biden's son when he was
vice president was clearly Shilling off
the president the extent to which Biden
was aware of what by what his son was
doing the extent to where there's a
famous email which talks about the big
guy getting 10 is the big guy 10 of a
very lucrative deal is the big guy Joe
Biden nobody quite knows uh I think the
drama around the pen office the Penn
Biden office could lead on to more
questions being asked about what what
were those business dealings in the sort
of years 2015 to 2019 what was Joe Biden
doing because he did make a lot of money
in that period uh and was it all kosher
that'll be the question and just finally
you mentioned how there's been a
reluctance in some parts to accept this
as a story and actually as time has gone
it's had to be taken more seriously do
you think um in that case we're talking
about classified information that Donald
Trump and Joe Biden have been treated
differently oh undoubtedly yeah uh I
think I mean
Biden supporters will say it's a
different type of story Trump seemed to
be holding the documents he'd been asked
to hand them over he didn't so the FBI
raided him whereas Biden has cooperated
fully uh with with with the authorities
the National Archives and the FBI
throughout that that's true to a certain
extent but the seriousness with which
Democrats talked about the importance of
classified documents as though you know
there's nothing worse in the world than
compromising National Security by being
slack or sloppy with national documents
compared to the way they talk about it
now which is this oh this is nothing you
know it'll go away I mean I think the
real story actually is that there's far
too many of these classified documents
Americans love classifying everything it
makes them feel sort of important uh and
uh they're just you know Mike Pence the
former vice president some documents
turned up in his house uh this week or
it was revealed that they turned up this
week and he you know he's another person
who's now got egg on his face so I think
the problem really is that there's all
these documents lying around everywhere
it's just how seriously people take them
thank you Freddie thank you for joining
this week great pleasure Katie
what are some of the most
fed words in the English language mate
fieldwork gory these are some of the
latest to go in the banned list by
groups who deem them harmful how much
further can they go I'm joined Now by
columnist Lana Shriver who wrote about
this in the magazine this week
thank you for coming on spectator TV uh
this week in your column you talk about
the words we're not supposed to say and
we're going to roll through a couple but
let's begin how you begin in your piece
housekeeping what's the problem
it doesn't qualify as any of the IST
words you know racist sexist ages Etc
um
but according to this University
Department in Washington it feels
gendered
and gender is in a way which is unfair
to women that's right because
I suppose it's something that women used
to do so there are a lot of a lot of
other things we might start eliminating
childbirth I've got a list
um if we stop Banning housekeeping how
does that actually manifest itself at
this University and the other words that
we're supposed to be using or that one
didn't come with a substitute but um
there are often in these Banning
documents that are now being issued
um in great quantity
unsurprisingly coming out of the
universities primarily
um
and they often tell you what you're
supposed to say instead
and unfailingly the substitutes are
awkward
um I'm really bad English sometimes even
ungrammatical uh a wordy and
um and don't mean the same thing at all
and actually Point here a lot of this is
coming from universities
um
is it because people are complaining or
ultimately these are academics looking
ahead and saying this these words should
not be used well
at a glance it seems as if these people
need to get a life right
um
but this is this this obsession with
language and and therefore uh
imposing virtue by Fiat from above uh by
means of controlling the words that
people are allowed to use this has been
an obsession of the left for decades now
and we've all been through the
what I call the euphemism churn of
constantly being told that whatever you
said last week and however you called a
certain group last week you can't do it
this week and we used to talk about the
disabled all the time and that was
supposed to be the polite term because
we were told we couldn't say handicapped
anymore
um and now you can't even say disabled
because all of these words that mean a
person
have been demonized because that's
reducing a a human being to a single
trait so now you have to say
um people living with disabilities this
you see what I mean I mean the
clumsiness and the wordiness is typical
this doesn't seem to bother these people
um because they're terrible writers and
uh I theorize in the column that maybe
this is part of the scheme to just make
sure that they don't have any
competition where we're all terrible
writers now
yeah and you mentioned the word disabled
but reading your column I discovered
apparently American is also something
which could be offensive that's correct
we're not supposed to talk about
Americans anymore the problem is that uh
both the both the North and South
continents
of America include many many different
countries and Americans have co-opted
the term too
to relate only to them and that's not
fair so they shouldn't be able to use
that word anymore
so I suppose the term offenses were
getting quite broader use these days
um what do you think offense do you
think there is such a thing as an
offensive word like how should we Define
what events the word is I presume that
you're not going to put America in that
bracket
um I find the expression birthing people
offensive
okay so I am capable of being offended
and I won't use it as a matter of fact I
find almost all of this leftist jargon
offensive it offends me that isn't
imposed on me it's ugliness offense
offends me
um it's
a Relentless and remorseless repetition
offends me bad writing offends me and
lack of thinking offends me because
behind a lot of these terms it's using
language as a substitute for thinking
for yourself I'll be seeing much sign of
it sleeping I suppose into the
mainstream yet because I'm reading your
column I found it fascinating that some
of these words that I've been using
briefly and we'll get to one which is I
think is
part of my podcast name wasn't the balls
he said ballsy and it is it's one that
is not supposed to be used
um but is there a sense that this is
still mainly in academic circles or
obviously you can see through
the trouble with this stuff is it does
tend to spread with plenty of evidence
of that there is almost an there was
almost a particular day in a particular
year when suddenly we stopped talking
about minorities I say we Loosely is I'm
I I'm moving mostly to the media you
couldn't say minorities anymore you had
to say people of color
and it was just is it it was as if
someone had passed a law it was so
Universal and it was so instantaneous
but I find the expression stilted it's
it's an Arcane construction it's absurd
and what makes it especially absurd is
that if you say colored people
you'll lose your job in fact people have
lost their job for saying colored people
by accident but what's the difference
I suppose if a group uh which is a group
that it's referring to is really
offended by that do you think that is
reason enough that people should you
know perhaps this is a matter of basic
courtesy start using other terms or is
that that then when it becomes a bit of
a slippery slope yeah
you anticipated my answer up to a point
yes and uh
although I seem to offend people all the
time I don't generally do it on purpose
uh so
up to a point I will comply and use
whatever term is acceptable and seems
respectful and
um but there's there's kind of a limit
because
especially in relation to the dis
disabled there's there have been so many
different words we're supposed to use
and you're not going to push me to use
an expression to the point of clumsiness
and
that would Mar the quality of my prose I
am not going to talk about people living
with disabilities or people living with
obesity
um
that's that's ridiculous and
accomplishes nothing right I don't see
why that's more respectful
it's just
bad English
so what is the best way to fight back
because and then my final question was a
the fight back but uh B
um you mentioned birthing but there any
words that you're going to ban for your
use and response
I don't think the answer is to fight
back by Banning after all that's the
problem I reject outright the idea that
people have the right to tell me which
words in the English language I may and
may not use
um so the first way you fight back is By
ignoring it right so
go ahead and use whatever words
pop into your head if they express what
you wanted to say then use them
and the other way to fight back is to
provide making fun of them and I find
that with uh the progressive left that's
the one thing they can't take
um they don't mind it if you call them
names and get angry
um and and seem mean and they don't even
mind it when you fight back with the
same kind of tactics that they use like
oh we're going to ban all this language
but they hate to be laughed at
and now on a slightly different topic
while we have you here I think a few
months ago when I was presenting
spectator TV you came on and he talked
about another of your columns which is
about Heating and I think it's one of
our most viewed clips of all time on
spectator TV
um so people can guess what the
Zeitgeist is but but we found it for
them and it's pretty cold at the moment
are you still sticking to your not
putting the heating on policy and that's
absolute emergency yes
um when I left uh our house was 10
degrees
and um
and
this is long underwear I won't show you
but I'm wearing
um long underwear underneath uh I walk
around in a coat
um
I get used to it but I type in gloves
and it's a little absurd but
uh I think I pointed out in our
discussion on this topic last time is
that I view turning on the heat as
defeat
yeah and your bills are looking good
well they're twice as much as they were
a year ago but everyone's is
still small to figure as a result
um thank you Lionel for paying on
spectator TV always a pleasure
and finally for the magazine Frank
Lawton interviewed the former Chief
restorer at the Vatican Maurizio De Luca
to learn about the unenviable task of
repairing million pound pieces of Fine
Art what happens when it goes wrong
and there's a little something lost in
the process sometimes a lot I'm now
joined by our Arts editor Eagle Terranea
leak to discuss
so Igor thank you for coming on
spectator TV um in the magazine this
week we have an interview with Maurizio
De Luca which lifts the lid on the hot
debate when it comes to art restoration
yes
um so this has triggered really by
um a really
terrible restoration at the National
Gallery it's a pure de la Francesca
Nativity that's had um two shepherds in
the background and they've been
retouched and restored
um in such a way that the garden calls
it kind of compared it to the to the
monkey Christ the famous monkey Christ
um from Northern Spain where those old
ladies
um completely messed up this uh Fresco
can you please talk us through The Good
the Bad and the Ugly when it comes to
art restoration the two massive
michelangelos that he he's focuses on in
this book and um some of those
um to me to my eyes strike me as kind of
a bit outlandish and
reduces the subtlety and and
the expression the the ambiguity of The
Originals there's these horses in the
convert this horse and the conversion of
Saul you have this like lovely kind of
expression on the horse's head in in the
original and it's completely gone
um you have um this complete like I I
find this baffling and it doesn't really
justify it in the book but he he
completely changes the entire layout and
look of Damascus in the background from
what looks like an oriental City to
something that is a Pastiche of a Roman
city which may may be justify by
academic evidence but looks just
hopeless
um and then there's also this kind of
very cartoonish
um update
um changing the features of this woman
in crucifixion
um where you know she's sort of in
Fright but actually in the original the
look could be many things it's more
ambiguous whereas in the updating it's
definitely she is frightened it's much
more like a I don't know like a a moment
in a film and then I suppose you were
showing me a couple before we started
recording and asked me which one I
thought was a restoration and I'm a
little bit too scared to say it in front
of you because I'm worried that I will
be shown to have no artistic taste
whatsoever
um but um is there such a thing as you
know uh a work of art that can ever
truly be restored or do you think every
time there is a restoration it will just
lose something definitely you're
essentially recreating the work you're
you're creating a 20th century version
of that work and there is something to
be said in in
in favor of this to some extent what
you're doing is you're you're making it
clear that actually these Renaissance
Works were probably far more vulgarly
crisp and far more cartoonish than we
imagine the the the the process of time
has made them really tasteful disheveled
subtle in all the things that we really
kind of respect but actually a bit like
Greek statues which are really like
disgustingly colored in like very bright
quite gaudy colors which I think would
shock us if we did it if we painted all
those white statues that we know and
love suddenly in these gaudy colors I
think we'd be pretty outraged
um but to some extent that brings us
closer to how they would have seen it on
the other hand there's a sort of there's
a lack of modesty in just saying that
you're you're essentially vandalizing
this word often the people who do the
most vandalism in throughout Society are
those who think they know at those who
think they know the the mind and have
the town of Michelangelo right
um so I suppose just finally on that
what do you think uh would happen you
know some of these original artists were
here today do you think that they would
be potentially horrified that the work
was being restored or were all uh do you
think perhaps they would think well at
least more people get to see it I think
I think they probably would be horrified
because the sort of academic instinct is
a modern one is is really a sort of
creation of the Enlightenment the idea
that these are their in perpetuity in a
certain way that we we ossify them is um
is something kind of it's much part of
modernity and I think these artists
would have would have felt an affinity a
close Affinity to someone like I mean
the Chapman brothers are famous for
essentially buying up a whole series of
Goya etchings and totally vandalizing
them I mean original Goya etchings
um and I think to some extent I mean I
don't really rate them
um not because they have vandalism I
think you can do good violence and bad
vandalism
um but because at least there's a sort
of honesty to the fact that they're
recreating something they they're
creating something new and so if DeLuca
was saying look I'm just I think I'm
better than Michelangelo then I would
have more respect yeah but it's the sort
of just say it maybe it is I mean I mean
to some extent that is the sort of
arrogance of a lot of these restorers
um so I I don't think someone like
Michelangelo would have respected that
at all
um thank you Eagle thank you for joining
us today pleasure
once again thanks to Canada wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes can Accord will provide you with
the expertise you need to help you build
your wealth of confidence visit can do
wealth.com for more information and
don't forget to also subscribe to The
Spectators YouTube channel just click
the Subscribe button at the bottom of
the video and tap the Bell icon so you
never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
thank you